my first question for the panel
what is a woman
and why and why
it don't they want to answer it and so
you can start and then go all the way
around
okay uh I believe that a woman is a
human being that is born with
certain areas of their body and their
mind that it's different is completely
different to a man that's the best way
I've never even been asked that question
but that's the best way I can describe
it
um
we
I believe a woman has a different mind
to a man a different wiring and a
completely different body and we also
have a completely different reproductive
system
okay
should I go last direction should I go
now you can go now or do you want to go
I'd like to hear the other answers okay
okay then you can go first
um to me a Woman by definition would be
someone who has two X chromosomes and
possesses a vagina as a standard okay
that's what I'd say
oh my God I don't know because it can't
be based on biological factors because
like women it doesn't matter anyway if
you have a vagina you know what I mean
so I'm like
I guess a woman is someone that feels
like a woman if you feel because I can't
even say something what if I when the
record stands
my record stance that's what I mean I
don't I can't really answer it I can't
lie okay okay go ahead I would say a
woman is you know same like these other
ladies what they said they've got two
breasts they've got a vagina they're
able to give birth that is a woman
um and also they've got sentimental
feelings you know
um yes a man could have a Sentimental
Feeling but I feel like with men
that's more of you know them finding
their feminine side you know so
that's the difference yeah that's what I
would say okay Auntie you wanna go
well I hope I know who I am or what I am
a woman's a female biological female
with a womb ovaries and a vagina
okay just yeah
um that's essentially what Auntie said
is a woman you're a biolog you're born a
female your vagina you have breasts you
have wounds you have ovaries and I think
the reason why they don't want to answer
it is because
they want to be politically correct or
whatever and
it's frustrating because I feel like if
you ask a dude what does it mean to be a
man they'll be able to say it when it
comes to women they say what does it
mean to be a woman like
um well you know and it's like that's
it's irritating because it's like oh oh
yeah what do you think about the guys in
this that that weren't answering are
they women
the people I've seen multiple videos and
it's people that have studied women's
whatever it is within women's and you
ask them what is women like you know
what is it to you it's like no we're
asking you because you studied it so you
tell us Mr Professor I'm just say that I
forgot that second part of what he was
asking us like why they won't answer it
yeah because if they answered it
truthfully they'll be all out of jobs
because they're they're making money
from Talking rubbish from fooling people
so
and the thing is I hate when you answer
a question with a question and that's
exactly what they did all the time so
imagine if they stood there after
teaching people or you can be this by
this and this trans this and you can
identify as this and then all of a
sudden they say we were lying
come on they're not gonna they might get
sued you know they'll be ostracized I
think that's why they don't answer
because they've been lying to people and
they don't want to tell the truth
yeah I mean shortest definition possible
a woman is an adult human female
um you've gone into more depth on
exactly what that means at 2x
chromosomes female reproductive capacity
womb cervix vagina the whole Plumbing
um
they're a completely different frame
um different body completely different
hormonal profile and so on to a man the
reason why those people won't answer
that question is number one
the reason why a small percentage of
people won't answer that is because
they're ideologically captured they're
ideologically possessed by gender
ideology which has roots going back many
many decades but the majority of them
won't answer it because they're cowards
simple as that 100 simple as that how do
you how do you yeah do you guys think
Bob risky and Kate Caitlyn Jenner
of course not so Caitlyn Jenner was
Bruce Jenner and then bobrisky the
Nigerian fashionista it was a man but
now he identifies it they were born as
men
oh okay you can't change your sex I mean
person I think they could be whatever
they want to be but you guys are like so
I have a question could I be a dog
if I identified it as a dog and I
started saying woof woof could I be a
dog if you identify it the way the rules
work if you identify it because it's the
same thing that's a whole different
species man that's like okay could she
be black yeah okay that's my next
question well currently now you can
um
oh I don't know man trans racialism
makes more sense than transgenderism
you say it makes more sense I said
transracialism makes more sense than
transgenderism how because race is
actually a spectrum race is actually a
social con gender is binary there's male
and female that's it there's nothing
else right race is actually a spectrum
right if I were to have a child with an
Asian woman my child is going to be
mixed if she is mixed and we have a
child the child is going to be race is a
it's a it's actually a social construct
yes it's based on our DNA and ancestral
history but these terms we use nobody's
actually black nobody's actually white
no one's actually these literal colors
right if someone is mixed race with the
fact that we even call them black
right if we call Drake black or we call
Barack Obama black right they're just as
white as they are black but due to the
social construct we call them black in
many cases so it's actually socially
constructed and it's genuinely a
spectrum you can meet someone and you're
like okay what race are you and it's
like well I don't know like my
grandparents are from here my mom's from
here my dad's from here you know but
their gender it's a simple binary so if
you can so it would make much more sense
for me to identify as I don't know a
different ethnicity identifies Jamaican
or identify as Indian that makes more
sense and is also more believable than
me identifying as a woman so if you're
opening the door and you're accepting
the arguments of transgenderism you'd
also have to if you're going to be
logically and rationally consistent
you'd also have to allow people to
identify as whatever race or ethnicity
perhaps nationality even age right it's
more believable that I'm 30 years old
than it is that I'm a woman right so why
can't I identify as 30. I look I look
like I could be 30. I feel like I could
be 30. so this is what people are
opening the doors to okay yeah identify
16. and people can do what they want by
the way so if you're an adult you can
live your life however you want right if
you're a man and you want to wear
dresses and take hormones and do
whatever you want you can but you are
never going to be a female you can't be
so for example if um
let's say pearl today she wakes up and
say oh I'm Jamaican I identify as a
Jamaican woman that's acceptable
I'm I'm saying it it would make more
sense than her saying that she's a man
is comparing the two facts I'm just I'm
saying transgender is saying that it
makes more sense because being a race is
something we created but in terms of
being a man and a woman that's a
biological thing God created yeah
so he's saying that if we humans didn't
create that someone's black someone's
white will all just be people that's
basically what yeah I mean product could
generally I mean she might feel black
she might someone might identify more
with black culture or Korean culture or
whatever
um but that would be left in fact this
has been because there are people who I
do identify as transracial and people
laugh at them but then those same people
will you know scream at you if you say
that a man can't be a woman and vice
versa right and it's one thing to be
polite and kind to people and I think
this is where you're coming from from a
compassionate angle I think mine is more
I don't like people I think people are
speaking from a position of Village
you're saying this because you've never
felt like you were something else
imagine being born a dog every day
imagine like imagine like you were born
in a body knowing that for you to come
out you're gonna take a lot of abuse
people were killed for this I just don't
believe that people were doing it just
for the sake of it I do think that's how
they've done you think that Society has
a part to play would it not if you're
getting killed for it but in terms of
like thinking oh yeah I'm a man or I'm a
woman as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible